increasingly dangerous.
>> Polo Sandoval we'll continue
to follow this story for us,
thank you.
>>> Continuing our national lead
burning man attendees are
burning out.
The music festival in Nevada's
BlackRock desert got messy when
two to three months of rain fell
in just a matter of hours.
It left tens of stranded in the
mud with dwindling supplies.
>> It's a real sloppy mess out
there.
>> Reporter: Tens of thousands
of people stuck at burning man
in the Nevada desert over the
weekend after heavy rains made a
mess of the dirt roads.
>> We drove out and got stuck
and made one bad decision it.
>> Was up to here.
>> Reporter: Hundreds of cars
ended up stranded on roads
leading out of the BlackRock
desert in the northwestern part
of the state.
>> Everything was shut down.
Getting out was a nightmare.
>> Reporter: Paul Romero and
his wife left maui's devastation
for what was supposed to be a
relaxing honeymoon.
>> It became a mini disaster for
a lot of people.
Entire camps became pretty much
destroyed.
It so was a lot of very trying
times for a lot of people.
>> Reporter: Less than an inch
of water fell over one 24-hour
period from Friday to Saturday.
>> So much water.
We are flooded.
>> Reporter: Organizers of the
week long festival asked
attendees to shelter in place
and to conserve food, water and
fuel.
>> It's definitely been very
festive.
Everybody is taking it in
stride.
>> Reporter: But not everybody
some so-called burners say the
mood was festive until supplies
started running out.
>> Everybody took their shoes
off they started dancing in mud
it was great.
Then the reality sunk in that we
couldn't leave.
>> Reporter: Apart from one
death over the weekend which
authorities say is not weather
related no serious injuries have
been reported.
>> Everybody was helping each
other out.
>> Reporter: But tens of
thousands are still slowly
inches their way out of the
event and the man burn and
enormouset to yemestdy of the
man -- effigy of the man has
been delayed unt tonight
making this year still an epic
event.
>> It is kind of a bonding
thing.
This will be one of those years
when you look back oh I was
there in 2023.
>> Reporter: And what you are
seeing here behind me is what
organizers call the ex-douse.
Many,le cars that are -- exodus
and they got to des separate
that they began walking.
Authorities are telling people
not to walk because it's safer
to be in a vehicle.
But look T's many people
that are going to stay inside
for that burn tonight.
So anybody that wants to get out
will be allowed to get out but
problem here is how long it's
going to take them to get out.
>> Burning man attendees are